there's this amazing story where
Superman kills the Joker and becomes a
dictator check this out so in this story
called Injustice Superman and Lois Lane
are gonna have a baby it's the lowest
Lane goes missing one day so Batman and
Superman and the rest of the Justice
League launch their own investigation
eventually Superman finds a submarine
where he thinks Lois Lane is being held
and when he breaks in instead of finding
Lois he finds the Joker and Harley Quinn
along with doomsday so Superman beats
the crap out of Doomsday and then flies
him into space come to find out what the
Joker had actually done is he had taken
scarecrow's fear Toxin and laced it with
green Kryptonite so it infected Superman
so when he broke in it wasn't doomsday
that was in that room it was Lois he
ended up killing his wife and his unborn
child not only that Lois's heartbeat was
tied to a nuclear bomb planted a
metropolis by The Joker so when she died
Metropolis was destroyed in a nuclear
blast after that Superman kills the joke
around the spot decides all criminals
have to go and then conquers the world
make sure you guys follow for more